[Music]
okay everyone this is my spoiler free
review of midnight mass
i was super hyped for this show i'm a
huge mike flanagan fan what got me extra
hyped was hill house was every episode
was directed by mike flanagan and
with blind manor that wasn't the case
but here every episode again is directed
by mike flanagan so
going into this again i had super high
expectations but
what ends up happening is you watch and
you go along the show it's more blind
manor than it is hill house so i don't
know if that makes you happy or sad
because blind manor was so divisive and
hill house was universally praised but
midnight mass
kind of falls into the same kind of
crutches flanagan has where
it's for good or worse the same old flan
again and what i mean by that is a
compliment
and not a compliment because
when i say same old flanagan he's
amazing thematically
he's an actor's director he gets the
best performances out of his actors and
in particular
hamish linklater who plays the priests
here you're gonna love he is a presence
and
he is so good that the best of the show
is every scene he's in it's that kind of
story where like he's on the screen it's
gonna be good uh zach gilford who plays
our leading man here the character of
riley amazing and
samantha slowin who was in hill house a
smaller role gets to shine here as a
main character brilliant performance
however
kate siegel who we know is theo from
hill house and she had a smaller part in
blind manner as a villain she gets a
leading role here she is criminally
miscast to me she plays more of a plane
character and i feel like she's better
as a roof around the edges characters i
feel like her
tools of the trade are used or wasted
right but i just cried to her when she
has to play certain moments that would
be easy for many actresses she kind of
drops the ball here so it's a
disappointing performance from her for
me where sometimes she looks like she's
a deer in headlights uh
but that's a mix of miscast but also
performance was lacking here so that was
surprising uh for someone who i really
like as an actress but again can't be
100 all the time
uh and you know one of my favorite
things about this show going back to
you know classic planning is great score
and this is my favorite score out of any
of the shows compared to blind manner or
hill house now
with the bad of classic flanagan is that
man he needs to tighten some things up
here and
some of these episodes they they're long
there's only seven episodes though so
it's like you can get by that but
there's a middle patch here there is an
episode episode four no spoilers but oh
my god it reminds you moments of my
manner where there's like
monologues that are like
10 minutes long and you're just sitting
there watching two people talk like
poets and you don't buy that these
people would actually talk like this so
it almost feels like work better in a
play or reading it in a book
so flanagan gets in his own way still
and doesn't fix a lot of the problems i
have he had in blime underwear it's
gonna really tune people out this show
uh
and it's for better or worse the same
thing where the show is always better
second watch with flanagan but i get if
you don't want to be down with that to
have to watch a show twice you know
first watch it's not that enjoyable
second watch it's much much better and
enjoyable so this is something that
happens with flan again you know and
i you go back you re-watch you'll catch
things it's cool you're like wow he
really set it up well but
you know there's some stuff you have to
suffer through to get the brilliance and
you're gonna see certain critics or
celebrities say like oh this is
brilliant all the way through it's not
it has brilliant moments but
you cannot ignore stuff that if you were
in a room with five people watching this
show there's gonna be moments you're
gonna look at each other and be like
what the hell is going on this is so
slow um
and you'll see some forced and stuff
and it gets sappy and there's good
moments of sap i'm not against zap but
there's it's better when it's wrapped in
horror and it works well sometimes he
goes full on like hallmark channel stuff
here which turned a lot of people off in
bly and that's going to happen again
here so i'm worried that there's going
to be people hyped up for a good horror
show and they're going to be tuning out
after episode 4. and it's unfortunate
because then episode 5 is like one of my
favorite episodes ever done so you're
going to get amazing episodes i think
the finale is incredible i think episode
5 is
insanely good my favorite episode of the
show so you get huge payoffs and rewards
but you got to work for those awards you
know so i wish flanagan would make it
like hill house where you don't feel
like you're working and you're getting
all of it you're getting entertainment
it feels tight good pace but again still
gets in his own way
and if you're looking for horror here
the horror works dramatically it's like
that way yeah the real horror stuff
we're like okay dramatically there's a
horror the themes of that the stuff that
scares you in real life that works the
stuff about faith is amazing this is a
personal story from mike flanagan he
grew up as an altar boy you're going to
get his full views now on faith and it
works so well but that's what he's good
at that's what we expect right
but
he's lacking in the horror department i
mean he does not give you many scares
here um i can't spoil what type of heart
is different type of genre he hasn't
done yet which she does well but if
you're looking for stuff to scare you
it's not here and it wasn't by manner
it's not here it's even lower than blind
manor so
if you're looking for scares this ain't
it so i i mean it's lightly labeled
horror but it's really a drama and it
has
you know
horrific themes if that makes sense but
it's not like
it's
again they really were tight about
spoilers in this situation so i can't
even say the subgenre of heart is which
works but it's not the one that scares
you if that makes sense so
you know it's going to be it's going to
be divisive just like blind manner i
guarantee you i mean and
it's totally worth the watch if you're a
mike flanagan fan and
you know overall i'm giving it an 8.4
and blind manner i gave it 8.7 and then
hunting field house averaged out i gave
a 9.4 so it's
to me
the lowest one in the total poll of this
shows but it's still really good and
you're gonna have a good time with it
it's heavy it's fresh in a lot of ways
but again i'm just disappointed that he
didn't you know get better at some of
his achilles heels he's just kind of
repeating some of those mistakes where
he really needs an editor someone just
opened their mouth and say
mikey you gotta tighten this up man or
like you gotta write this a little more
like actual people talking and not you
know socrates just talking here not
everyone is a philosopher so if you're
getting scenes where they're so drawn
out and just talking about life he gets
so boring so um yeah i'm actually see
i'm really interested the audience
reaction for this one but uh
i think most people enjoy it like blind
manor but you're gonna have people hate
this thing and i mean you're gonna have
some serious tests of patience those
first four episodes so more power to you
get rewarded for it but you wonder how
much
effort drive to put in to get the reward
and is that a problem is it a problem
that a show is only good sometimes with
him if you watch it twice i don't know i
don't know i don't really have opinion
on it but i'll tell you this if you're
down for that you're gonna love it way
more the second time like it was a blind
manner and you're gonna get some great
stuff so
enjoy it i really wanna hear you guys
thoughts on this you're gonna see a full
big big spoiler review i have coming out
friday when the show drops so make sure
to check that out uh and
yeah make sure to comment below your
thoughts you're going to watch us are
you excited what are you expecting give
me your thoughts too about hill house
and blind man or i love to hear that
well as well again down here so
yeah you know make sure to save i have a
preview link for the spoiler review so
make sure to save that as a reminder
it's going to be fun time uh
please subscribe to my channel you know
i do a bunch of reviews celebrity
interviews if you really love what i do
here i appreciate if you can become a
member and donate it'll help me do more
reviews for you guys and do this full
time one day and you get perks as well
so why not and please follow me at steve
are the show on twitter instagram and
tick tock for more of me i'll see you
next time